تنسحب الالف من توقم سيارات الاسعاف في
خدمه الصحيه الوطنيه عنايه اساس بريطانيا
وويلز من اعمالهم لرفض الحكومه زياده
الاجور فوق معدلات التضخم مما زاد الضغط
على الخدمات الصحيه التي تملها الدوله
وقالت الحكومه البريطانيه الى الاضراب
سيؤدي الى عدد اقل من سيارات الاسعاف على
الطريق مع اعطاء الاولويه للحالات الاكثر
حاحا التي تهدد الحياه كنوبات القلبيه
ياتي ذلك بعد اضرابات الممرضين الاخيره في
ظلي رفض الحكومه قبوله المطار المتعلقه
بالاجور
مين لندن بوراسات العربيه عروب عبد الحق
امامنا اسابيع ساخنه جدا في بريطانيا
الممرضين وايضا السكك الحديديه وباقي
القطاعات ومطار هيثرو اليوم بدا مع
الممرضين
كيف ينعكس هذا على المرضى خاصه انه اصلا
تعاني خدمه سحر الوطنيه
سيارات
وهو ياتي بعد يوم من اضراب الممرضين الذي
كان امس في ثاني يوم لهم مما يعني ان هناك
ضغط كبير على القطاع الصحي التوصيل من
الحكومه يعني جاءت بتوخي الحذر اليوم عدم
الانخراط في الانشطه خطيره كما قالت ولكن
يعني من غير يعني لا نعلم اذا كانت هذه
بالنسبه لبلد مثل البريطانيا يعني لندن
فيها حوالي تسعه مليون شخص والمدربين عن
همم المدربين اليوم 10 الاف موظف من
سيارات الاسعاف وهذا رقم مهم جدا وانه
الحالات همم حالات القلب اولويه طيب كيف
بيعرف شخص على الاتصال اذا كان بانيك اتاك
او اعرض قلب يعني من الصعب احيانا التفرقه
طيب عروب بعد في سؤال ماذا يريد هؤلاء ما
هي طلبات الممرضين
خدمات الابلنس
يعني الموظفين في مجال الاسعاف لم يطلبوا
نسبه معينه لزياده الاجور بخلاف الممرضين
الذين طلبوا زياده بنسبه 19% ولكن هناك
كانت زياده بنسبه
4,7-7-5% وهم يقولون لان هذه الزياده
مهينه بحققهم باعتبار انهم الاكثر كانوا
متضررا خلال جائع حتى جائحه كورونا
الخلافات طبقه بين الحكومه والنقابات
التي رايناها اليوم تقول بان بان موظفي
السيارات وهم لم يقبلوا المرضى بل الحكومه
هي التي خذلت المرضى بسبب رفضها همم
بريطانيا مقبله على اضرابات من يريد ان
يذهب هناك من العالم العربي ويتابعنا عليه
توخي الحذر لانه حتى
يعني يشهد ربما بعد التاخيرات شكرا لك
مراسلات العربيه عروب عبد الحق